there's actual bit of debate over how I
should pronounce this I call it sequel
injection the acronym is SQL whichever
way you call it it's a way to attack
websites that really shouldn't work
anymore but still does sequel or SQL is
a language in which you talk to
databases and it's fairly like English
actually you can actually say things
like select from this table it's not a
complicated language there are no great
amounts of curly brackets and semicolons
and things like that it can be but
equally you can pretty much type
commands in near English into it and
you'll get results back from your
database and this has existed for years
and years and years and that was all
fine until the web came along and now
people are looking at websites and I
thinking these these need to be hooked
up to databases because way back when
when when Tim berners-lee invented the
world wide web it was pretty much I'm
gonna request a document and you're
going to send that document back to me
eventually people worked out that what
you really wanted to do was was send a
document and have different things come
back depending on what you've sent maybe
you could type in a search request and
that would go to a database and pull
back something that's great that's
that's brilliant that's a a wonderful
invention and unfortunately some
programming languages are dealt with
this in a sensible way and some did not
and one of the most notable ones that
didn't is a language called PHP I'm a
PHP code err it's a very easy language
to write in it's a friendly language I
still haven't met any other language
that lets me develop code at the speed
that I'm able to it's very fault
tolerant a hole in reason doesn't always
give you the best results when heat when
it does but you know it's it's friendly
it's easy to pick up and crucially you
can just write it into a text file
upload it to a web server in most of the
world and it'll just work you can type
in PHP code and have it just run so the
barrier to entry is really really low
which in one way is brilliant it makes
web programming much more accessible
Facebook was originally written in PHP
innumerable things have originally been
written in PHP and loads of things still
are wordpress still is the trouble is
that if you're not careful there's a lot
of ways to go wrong this isn't just PHP
then I'll used as an example you talk to
a database by issuing a command like
this select star from users where
username equals Tom great and the
database will send back all the details
it knows about the user called Tom
brilliant but the catch is those
quotation marks because if I'm not
careful about what I send then we could
cause some problems let's say for
example that I have a web form that lets
me log in and I type in Tom and it sends
that it brings back Tom ok
now let's say I type in Tom with a quote
mark in it and if you're not careful
what will happen is the language will
send something like this selector of
uses where username equals Tom and then
I put a quote mark in and then it puts a
quote mark in it fails because the pock
marks don't match up and the whole thing
crashing it just sends back an app
that's mildly annoying and a big form of
course of is putting in any text that
has quote marks the catch is you can do
a lot of damage that way because that
language doesn't just have select it has
insert to add new stuff it has update to
change stuff and it has delete to remove
stuff so if I were to send say a
username that was Tom sent out close
quotes semicolon and then put another
command in there like delete everything
it's not a literal command but something
like that it would work so have a look
at how that works we've got the normal
command select star from users where
username Tom long commander but when you
put in Tom I'm going to send that and
then I'm going to send this
drop all databases hit enter it will get
converted into a plain English command
in SQL language it will get sent and the
database will go well that's exactly
what I should do it's going to
understand that there's a new command at
the semicolon and that it should delete
everything
the main way around it is escaping when
there is a dangerous character like a
quote mark you put a slash before it and
by you I mean you the program of writing
this you go through and you use a
function that says everywhere there is a
quote mark put this slash before it and
before you send it to the database you
do that input comes in from the user and
some slashes to it to make it safe send
it out to the database and the database
looks those slashes and goes right every
time is one of those this thing that's
coming next just treat it as a regular
quote mark don't treat it as anything
special eight in the text just treat it
as that and if you want to send an
actual slash you send two slashes the
first one to say treat the next one is a
real character and then it works but
it's clunky um and for awhile this kind
of send the command in plain English was
the only way to make things work in a
couple of languages including PHP the
most commonly used web programming
language in the world to make this worse
the command to add those slashes was the
wonderfully unwieldy my sequel to name
the database real escape underscore
strength and then you put whatever text
you want that escape string being what
you wanted to do my C for being the name
of the database and real because the
first one didn't work and they couldn't
change it because of backwards
compatibility so anyone who uses the
original string which is like more than
ten years ago now but anyone who'd use
the original form of this completely
insecure rather than patch that they
just added the word real anyone who
forgot to add that or haven't read
through all the documentation yeah
anyone can come along and effectively
delete your database or do more subtle
things like update other people's
accounts or read other people's
passwords because once you've got access
to the database if you work out how it
works
there's really
much you can't do and the thing is it is
so easy to get this wrong if you get
this wrong just once
anywhere in your code and there are lots
of really subtle ways that I'm not going
to go into to get this wrong it's not
just a case of forgetting to escape
quotes um there are lots of really
subtle ways to get it wrong if you do
that then your web app is vulnerable and
if someone figures out that there's a
way in there because they try and create
a username with a quote mark in it then
good luck say goodbye to everyone's
passwords the way it should be done is
something called prepared statements and
if you are programming anything to do
with the database you should be using
prepared statements right now um the way
they work is it's a it's a hack on top
of a hack because let's be honest
sending that kind of plain English
sequel command from a programming that's
a hack and then we've had to put more on
top of that and more on top of more on
top of that but prepared statements at
least keeps it safe with prepared
statements you send the query you send
select star from users where username
equals and then you just say question
mark and that question mark you then
later say right this is the data I'm
putting in this is not to command don't
do anything to this no matter what it
looks like this is unsafe just take it
treat it very gingerly store it in the
database and don't look at it beyond
that it's a little more complicated that
I'm simplifying massively for you know
talking to a camera
and if your web programming you should
look up the the recent security
guidelines of what you should do website
transcend protect but this is what you
should be using because right now if
you're not using prepared statements it
takes one mistake
anywhere in your application one thing
where you've forgotten to put a quote
marking and mess it up in some subtle
way that uses Unicode character or
something wonderfully complicated
particularly using a Microsoft database
to us from someone who uses Windows if
you're not using for paired statements
you are vulnerable
and you need to fix that but in the
meantime those hacks go there are worse
ones
the adverbs are generating revenue for
that page in order to do that and that's
where cookies get controversial the
example I've given you is what's called
first party cookies